well the senate kicks starting its lame
duck session with a long to do list
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
says he wants to pass more coronavirus
relief and a new package of spending
bills before the end of the year
chad pergram live for us on capitol hill
and chad what can we expect exactly in
the weeks ahead
you know sometimes it's easier to get
things done during a lame duck congress
sometimes it's harder now mitch
mcconnell
has made no bones about it that he wants
to do another coronavirus bill something
that's smaller he's in the driver's seat
right now he may prefer to get something
done
under the trump administration rather
than wait until january
and one senator who has long wanted a
smaller coronavirus bill
is republican mitt romney of utah
conservative principles are still on the
ascendancy in this country
i don't think america wants to sign up
for the green new deal
or getting rid of coal and oil and gas
or medicare for all house speaker nancy
pelosi had taken the lead in coronavirus
talks
she negotiated on a daily basis with the
secretary of the treasury steve mnuchin
on a larger 2.2 trillion dollar bill
mcconnell wants something more targeted
especially after a good jobs figure on
friday
with democratic losses in the house
there are questions as to whether pelosi
would take
a smaller deal no
no it doesn't appeal to me at all
because they still have not agreed to
crush the virus
if you don't crush the virus we're still
going to have to be dealing
with the consequences of the virus
here's what they do have to do they have
to fund the government the deadline
there is december 11th
they also have to wrestle with the debt
ceiling either raising it or suspending
it
and they also have to deal with the
defense authorization bill trace
just curious chad a lot of buzz on
capitol hill about the working
relationship between
joe biden and mitch mcconnell
yeah you know they actually were pretty
good friends and there was a very
striking moment
in late december 2016 where mitch
mcconnell renamed part
of the 21st century cures act after
bobine not hunter biden of course we've
heard a lot about him but bo biden who
succumbed to cancer here
there is a cordial relationship and i
checked in earlier today to ask
if mitch mcconnell had had any outreach
to the biden campaign to the biden
transition team
and they don't have anything just yet
chad program live for us on capitol hill
chad thank you